c'est le premier débat de la soirée pour
ou contre l'euthanasie c'est le premier
match la championne c'est agathe
l'assemblée de la semaine dernière elle
va et et on va essayer bien sûr de la
détrôner agathe est ce que vous êtes
pour ou contre l'euthanasie
je suis pour la navette pour
l'euthanasie qui est contre ici autour
de la table qui est contre albert
christine à l'albert bien fait au
premier match contre agathe recours
contre ces partis à la rencontre le
canadien lui 25000 réactions sur les
réseaux et je vous le dis ça alors il ya
chacune qui nous a rejoint ajacides
merci d'être là n'ayant gens dont on va
parler avec vous voilà jacqueline vous
avez programmé votre mort vous avez 74e
mais pour le moment on fait ce débat
juste après vous avez tous nous rajeunit
pas ce que c'est fou alors vous vous
êtes contre vous vous êtes pour une
minute trente chacun en a rajouté 30
secondes par rapport à la semaine
dernière dont d'aller essayer de
détrôner agathe nouveautés qui vous a le
plus convaincu
c'est parti on démarre par la championne
vous êtes pour pourquoi alors je suis
pour la légalisation de l'euthanasie en
france précisément quand elle concerne
les personnes atteintes de maladies
incurables qui souffrent le martyre sur
leur lit d'hôpital et je trouve que
refuser le droit de mourir à une
personne dans la souffrance
c'est tout simplement inhumain n'ont pas
le droit de moi on leur à nos fils votre
père du joueur est alors et les
séditieux laisser leur entrée dans ce
cas le plus cool il vient parce que
c'est pas ça du tout déjà là on parle de
suicide à tal qui tous ici si tu as lu
certaines choses et tu es induit les
personnes en erreur hayat console c'est
ce débat avec lord dure depuis un
certain temps tu sais qu'il ya des soins
palliatifs absolument l aurais tu sais
ça à conteneurs
certains docteurs il prépare des
cocktails moi j'ai été voir une personne
on a discuté et je lui ai demandé très
honnêtement pourquoi vous voulez mourir
parce qu'elles souffrent oui oui mais
quand tu lui pose la question si vous
pouviez vivre elle te dis oui je
voudrais vivre et adam riess voit les
questions c'est pas de se demander si on
doit leur donner la mort les question
c'est de savoir comment on peut les
faire vivre avec une perspective de
guérison et le débat sur l'euthanasie
est extrêmement hypocrite défensif de
guérison l'euthanasie dite passive est
tolérée en france l'euthanasie passive
est acceptée c'est à dire que les
médecins effectivement peuvent
administrer des soins palier des soins
j'aurais bien soulagé le bal des choses
qui sont réels ils peuvent te rends
compte de la saga compte que je suis
touché agathe quand tu parles designs
non je ne fais pas exprès et c'est pas
drôle je te connais absolument pas drôle
non
je vais t'assurer vraiment parler de ces
gens là ces gens là ils veulent vivre
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression de m'être
de l'affect et mon histoire personnelle
et ma l'histoire de ma grand-mère dans
des débats de société là c'est pas du
tout le sujet évidemment je puis ma
grand-mère donc le belge pour moi non
plus deux pour moi non plus n'importe
quoi tu meurs en toucher les gens par
les femmes en souffrent du mois sans
perspective de guérison souffrent se met
d'accord s'ils se demande sans
perspective de guérison incurable
transhumance en perspective de twilight
aurait plus on est jeune encore plus oui
je veux mourir s'il vous plaît aidez moi
ça devrait être acceptée et depuis peu
changé depuis que c'est légal en
énormément de moyens belge qu'il la
pratique du tout et qui raconte de
passion
de quitter les médias pas beau si
seulement les gens par les sentiments is
le débat il mérite beaucoup plus qu'une
simple réflexion a survolé les mercis
retourne à vos places retourne à votre
merci merci